[Music]
universal's 1999 remake of the mummy was
a cultural reset for both the property
and hollywood as a whole it arguably
changed action movies helping usher in
the era of cgi villains and heavily
comedic heroes one of those heroes
rachel vice's evelyn carnahan propels
the action of the first mummy film she
is the one who recognizes the
significance of the puzzle box that
leads them to the city of hamanopdra she
reads the incantation that awakens emote
and it is her soul that the undead
priest wants to give to his dearly
departed girlfriend evelyn is a huge
part of the mummy franchise's appeal
fans love the movie's blend of action
romance and comedy all of which vice
contributes to she channels screwball
comediennes of the 30s for her sparkling
performance the stranger noted in its
review how perfect she was to play
evelyn saying she has all the spunk and
ditzy charm you'd expect from a heroine
who can proudly proclaim she's not just
smart she's a librarian for goodness
sake
let's be nice children
the mummy series arguably fell off when
vice failed to return for the mummy tomb
of the dragon emperor the third
installment in the mummy series a
representative of ice told digital spy
that she didn't want to go to china and
spend so much time away from her at the
time newborn son after leaving the mummy
franchise vice went on to work steadily
in movies both big and small but her
most critically acclaimed work of late
has been on a much smaller scale than
the mummy rachel vice won an academy
award not long after the mummy returns
for her performance in the 2005
adaptation of john lichterrez the
constant gardener the film centers on
rafe finds justin quail who tries to
solve the murder of his wife vice plays
the ill-fated wife tessa an amnesty
activist in kenya vice also has had some
brief dalliances with other blockbuster
franchises post mummy the same year she
starred in the constant gardner she made
a foray into comic book adaptations with
the cult favorite constantine she'd go
on to star in the bourne legacy opposite
jeremy renner before doing her time in
the mcu playing melina vostikov in black
widow in 2021 vostikov is something of a
mother figure to scarlett johansson's
natasha romanov and florence pugh's
yelina bilova as of yet there's been no
word if bosticoff will return to the mcu
but there's little doubt fans would
adore seeing her again while vice's
experience with blockbusters is
extensive her most notable work of late
has been in more indie fair vice first
worked with greek director jorgos
lantimos on his 2015 black comedy the
lobster she played a woman searching for
love before she gets turned into an
animal she would reunite with lantimos
for 2018's the favorite in which she
plays lady sarah churchill lady sarah
starts the film as the titular favorite
of queen anne played by olivia coleman
as well as her secret girlfriend emma
stone plays abigail who woos the queen
away from lady sarah in an attempt to
stay in power in court coleman won an
academy award for her performance as
queen f the apex of the unlikely love
triangle while stone and vice were both
nominated for best supporting actress
the same year as the favorite vice
starred in disobedience opposite rachel
mcadams the drama focuses on two women
from the orthodox jewish community who
try to reconcile their love for each
other with their sometimes overbearingly
strict community
despite being married to a man daniel
cred aka james bond vice's performances
in these films have vault advice into
queer icon status in the lgbtq community
vice's queer turn may have something to
do with the fact that she's primarily
focused on women-centered stories she
told the new york times i really enjoy
all the thousands of movies i've seen
about men i mean there are some great
masterpieces but there's just a darth of
ones about women i love women women are
just really fascinating and different to
men fans can likely expect this trend to
continue with vice's future projects
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]